you just got engaged so how are you
feeling about all your support
you got to do it you know it's just part
i know it's always like it's like what
sorry what it's so funny when we got
engaged so many friends and family were
like
thank you i'm like why like thank you
for giving us something to look forward
to i was like oh yeah we totally did it
for you guys
the emily and ferris star and her fiance
charlie mcdowell
don't have a wedding date yet but lily
says plans are
in the works meanwhile her main co-star
amanda seifried surprised everyone
with the birth announcement of her
little boy seven weeks ago after keeping
her pregnancy a secret
is little nina is nina loving being a
big sister now
the best big sister that i
i've ever seen she is obsessed with him
and when she walks into the room
he finds her he just bites her he moves
his head and he finds her shall i call
you herman please call me man
the ladies play real-life characters in
their new netflix movie that debuts
december 4th
shot entirely in black and white this
love letter to old hollywood depicts the
drama surrounding the making of citizen
kane and its scriptwriter herman
mankowitz
known as mank i grew up loving old
hollywood
so i i found it really fun to do
research
and to kind of envelop myself in this
world in a whole new way
amanda's getting rave reviews for her
portrayal of william reynold purse
mistress
miriam davies someone saved me
is it true that you had to do one scene
over 200 times i didn't actually count
so it could be
a little bit less or probably more